[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und claus kleber
guten abend in einigen wochen wenn es
allmählich herbst wird in deutschland
wird delta eine sehr viel potentere
version des queen corona virus auf eine
deutlich bessere verteidigung treffen
dank impfung es ist aber nicht
garantiert dass das gut geht noch sind
die impfquoten nicht da wo sie hin
sollten und mit dem argument würde sich
kein regierender rausreden können wenn
neue lok downs nötig würden andererseits
wollen sie den wählern jetzt nicht mehr
massnahmen zumuten als die bereit sind
einzusehen bei harmlos wirkenden
instanzen zurzeit britta spiekermann
über den politischen seiltanz heute und
sein ergebnis
alles wie gehabt und doch ganz anders
schließlich sind bald wahlen markus
söder bayerischer ministerpräsident und
der regierende bürgermeister von berlin
müller merkel ist schon da zur video
schalte im kanzleramt der ton ist
überaus sanft auf der anschließenden
pressekonferenz der appell gemeinsam an
all diejenigen die es noch nicht getan
haben sich möglichst sofort unbedingt
impfen zu lassen
die bisherigen impfquoten reichen
einfach nicht aus um sorglos zu sein wir
bekommen die gefahr einer pandemie de
ungeimpften das ist eine ansage
unmissverständlich wer sich nicht impfen
verhalte sich unsolidarisch seit einer
gefahr für sich und für andere
deswegen sind sich diese drei einig der
druck muss erhöht werden und deshalb
werden
die kostenlosen bürger test für alle mit
wirkung vom 11 oktober beenden das heißt
für alle diejenigen die sich impfen
lassen könnten und es ist schon bitter
dass auch zu sehen dass so viele immer
noch vorbehalte haben oder angebote
nicht annehmen kostspielig wird das
mitte oktober für all die impfwilligen
ein test wird unter 20 euro kosten sagt
das
bundesgesundheitsministerium hat einer
inzidenz von 35 soll es eine testpflicht
geben ökonomischer druck impfpflicht mit
diesem etikett will keiner der
anwesenden nach hause gehen wir wollen
keine impfpflicht jeder entscheidet
selbst ob er sich impfen lassen will
oder nicht aber jeder in einem
freiheitlichen staat trägt dafür auch
die verantwortung
noch gilt die dreijährige zutritt für
geimpfte genesene oder getestete
allerdings könnte aus 3g schnell zweig
werden eine zweiklassengesellschaft wer
keinen lockdown will und unlocker und
wird auch nicht mehr geben doch dann
dazu nicht mehr geben auf keinen fall
für zwei geben stehen warum weil es
verfassungsrechtlich gar nicht so dass
die geheimsten werden dann auch
sicherlich anders behandelt als die
nicht geimpften wenn man eine weitere
steigerung desinfektions geschehens hat
sanftem ton niemand soll in
wahlkampfzeiten über gebühr erschrecken
und doch der druck auf skeptiker oder
unwilliger wird größer wer sich nicht
impfen lässt könnte bei hoher incident
aus dem gesellschaftlichen leben
ausgeschlossen werden ein szenario auf
wiedervorlage
der ministerpräsident von
nordrhein-westfalen und kanzlerkandidat
der union war nicht auf der bühne in
berlin aber virtuell dabei wie die
meisten anderen regierungschefs einen
schönen guten abend herr laschet
guten abend herr kleber sagen wir es
doch wie es ist sie treiben die
unwilligen zur impfung wie ein cowboy
seine rinder in den choral warum machen
sie sich nicht ehrlich und sagen wenn
das nicht reicht dann kommt in
irgendeiner form im pflicht das ist
immer noch besser als lockte
wir haben heute eine inzidenz von
23,5 in deutschland und deshalb haben
wir heute
analysiert wo stehen wir und wir haben
uns vorgenommen alles zu tun anreize zu
erhöhen damit sich mehr menschen impfen
lassen und das ist heute gelungen in
einer sehr kurzen mpk sie wissen wir
haben ja nur ein ganz wichtiges thema
ebenfalls beschlossen nämlich die
fluthilfe mit 30 milliarden für die
betroffenen leid mehrere lasche bitte
mal das ist ein thema
das in der weihnachtszeit tut mir leid
dass wir jetzt gleichzeitig mehr her
aber ich muss darauf bestehen dass wir
bei unseren fragen und beim bau unserer
sendung bleiben denn wir kommen noch auf
die fluthilfe zu sprechen kommen wir
zurück auf das was wir gerade sagen sie
sagen sie bauen druck in richtung
impfung argumentiert wird er immer mit
dem freiheitsbegriff tatsächlich muss es
ihnen aber darum gehen die zahl der
geimpften zu erhöhen und da sagt ihr
kollege markus söder gerade unseren
freunden von dem anderen sender das
werde notfalls jetzt auf rauslaufen das
getestet gar nicht mehr gilt also man
wird entweder
gewesen sein oder genf sein oder
ausgeschlossen von bestimmten
veranstaltungen und er sagt außerdem
dass haben manche noch nicht sagen
wollen weil die form wahlkampf die leute
nicht erschrecken wollen würden sie
diese darstellung von herrn söder teilen
also ich wollte ihnen das erstes nur mit
der flut sein dass die zeit sehr knapp
war und wir sehr viel geschafft haben
und geschafft haben wir dass wir uns
heute darauf geeinigt haben die anreize
zum impfen zu erhöhen das war heute das
ziel dass es gelungen tests wird es dann
verpflichtend geben in innenräumen und
wer sich der solidargemeinschaft
entzieht wird in zukunft auch für seine
tests bezahlen müssen und ich gehe davon
aus und das war die einhellige meinung
aller ministerpräsidenten dass es uns so
gelingt die impfquote nach oben zu
bringen von 2 und 3 g ba heute nicht die
rede sondern von dem ziel mehr menschen
zum impfen zu bringen denn der geimpfte
wird keinen lockdown mehr erleben das
war unsere klare botschaft und die gilt
auch für den heutigen tag aber nicht
geimpfte man achte sehr auf die
zwischentöne hier nicht geimpfte werden
so was wie ein loch da und erleben weil
sie an manchen dingen dann eines tages
nicht mehr teilnehmen können verstehe
ich sie da richtig
heute heute sind wir einig test geimpft
oder gelesen das ist die kategorie mit
der wir arbeiten und wir tun alles dass
die zahlen unten bleiben und über ein
szenario dass wir wie der
kanzleramtsminister einmal gesagt hat
weil inzidenz von 700 oder 800 sind
darüber haben wir heute nicht gesprochen
weil die ganze kraft jetzt darauf gehen
muss mehr menschen zum impfen zu bringen
vor allem die die vielleicht bisher sich
dazu dich entscheiden konnten aber gar
keine impfgegner sind sondern aus
vielerlei gründen das nicht mitgemacht
haben die müssen wissen es wird für sie
schwerer sie werden an bestimmten dingen
nicht mehr
ohne test teilnehmen können und sie
werden den auch selbst bezahlen müssen
und das ist auch fair gegenüber den
vielen geimpften die einen beitrag zur
solidargemeinschaft leisten und das
szenario dass möglicherweise irgendwann
wenn es alles eskaliert eintreten könnte
das war heute kein thema und ich finde
wir sollten auch jetzt alles tun damit
wir diese impfquote nach oben bringen
ich bin zuversichtlich dass das auch
gelingen kann das haben wir inzwischen
verstanden ich habe jetzt immer noch das
gefühl dass eines tages die tests nicht
mehr den zugang verschaffen werden aber
als erste als erste maßnahme heute jetzt
die tests teuer und damit als ist
kostenpflichtig und damit schwieriger zu
machen warum soll deutschland ein
sicheres land werden wenn weniger leute
das geld für den test ausgeben ich weiß
es gibt den ausweg mit der impfung das
aber genügend besprochen aber warum
werden sanktionen nämlich geld zu
verlangen für tests das land sicherer
machen
ja weil sie in bestimmte bereiche dann
nicht mehr hinein kommen die tests
funktionieren gut wir müssen auch die
test quote erhöhen kinder nuten wird es
zweimal die woche zu und ich finde dass
der der dann in innenräumen ist das auch
auf sich nehmen muss wenn er nicht
geimpft ist und diese
und sie bestehen aber nicht zum beispiel
was ihr kollege lauterbach vorgeschlagen
hat auf pcr tests dafür gebe es
medizinische gründe war die
zuverlässiger sind davor schrecken sie
offenbar im moment zurück
die ministerpräsidenten schrecken davon
nicht zurück sondern die tests die wir
haben sind bewährt wir sollten auch
jetzt nicht den menschen das gefühl
vermitteln dass die tests nichts wert
sind sie sind wichtig wir brauchen mehr
tests und das ist in diesem moment das
hauptziel sicherheit zu gewährleisten
noch einmal erklärt bei einer inzidenz
von
23,5 in deutschland sie haben die
inzidenz grenze 35 jetzt eingeführt
nachdem alle versichern die inzidenz
sollen nicht mehr der maßstab sein wurde
die inzidenz wieder als maßstab
eingeführt warum sind sie nicht weiter
mit dem fortschritt und haben inzwischen
irgendwas ein leuchtendes
komplizierteres dass auch dinge wie zum
beispiel die krankenhaus belegungen die
die intensivbetten und so weiter mit
berücksichtigt es werden ja gewiss genug
zeit das auszuarbeiten
das lka arbeitet weiter daran wir haben
heute zum ersten mal in einem beschluss
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz gesagt
es sind drei faktoren die incidents die
hospitalisierung also die krankenhaus
belegung und die impfquote eigentlich
gesagt wie man nur sprechen jeweils die
lage beurteilen ich habe das lka hat uns
noch keinen rechten schlüssel vorgelegt
sondern wir haben gesagt bei allen
entscheidungen müssen diese drei
kategorien berücksichtigt werden dass
fließt auch in alle entscheidungen im
moment ein und ich finde das ist ein
großer schritt ich habe da lange für
geworben nicht nur auf die instanzen zu
schauen und das hilft uns jetzt noch
besser die lage zu analysieren wie ist
es wirklich mit krankheitsfällen das
kann man durch diesen neuen faktor der
seit erstem august gilt jetzt auch vom
rk erfahren danke schön herr laschet für
das gespräch und wir kommen jetzt auf
das andere thema
das große virtuelle powwow der
länderregierungschefs mit der kanzlerin
drehte sich wie schon gesagt nicht nur
um die pandemie sie haben dort auch ein
30 milliarden euro schweres hilfspaket
für die opfer der flutkatastrophe
gepackt 30 milliarden euro das ist ein
so großer haufen geld das ist ein gesetz
braucht ihn auszugeben und das wurde
heute ganz schnell und einig angeschoben
niemand wollte mit bedenken im wege
stehen wenn hilfe so offensichtlich und
dringend gebraucht wird susanne gelhard
berichtet
cornelia weigandt verbands
bürgermeisterin von altena amtiert
provisorisch in einem hotel am rathaus
ist nach dem hochwasser unbrauchbar hier
versuchen sie nun eine vorläufige
schadensbilanz und die sieht
erschreckend aus dass zu hause ist
zerstört das sind die arbeitsplätze der
menschen die betriebe sind zerstört dass
es das thema wir leben mehrheitlich von
weinbau und tourismus das ist zerstört
wir brauchen straßen sind zerstört wir
brauchen normal wasser abwasser strom
das ist zerstört die eisenbahnlinie ist
zerstört also egal wo sie anpacken es
ist wirklich alles zerstört das ahrtal
hat es am härtesten getroffen 62 brücken
800 kilometer schiene hunderte kilometer
straße wurden überspült
42.000 menschen sind betroffen die
verbindungen nach draußen wieder
aufbauen menschen hoffnung geben auch
das sollte er hilfsfond leisten den bund
und länder heute beschlossen mit dieser
zusage dass deutschland gemeinsam steht
bei dieser großen nationalen
herausforderung denke ich sollte das
auch ein signal sein an sie alle dass
man wirklich auch und bereit ist zu
unterstützen und den wiederaufbau für
alle zu ermöglichen
in der zentralen einsatzleitung des thw
in bonn ist neben einsatzorten weltweit
das hochwassergebiet im aartal seit mehr
als drei wochen ein schwerpunkt wichtig
ist erstmal das sage ich mal alle
elementaren also die hauptstraßen
bereiche die brückenbauwerke die
schienen bauwerke und so weiter
hergestellt werden um schnell in die
schadens gebiete rein und raus zu
bekommen die logistik und lebensmittel
und so weiter das dass sicher gestellt
ist und dann natürlich der lebensart
eine bevölkerung wasser gas strom
bis september soll die versorgung
provisorisch sichergestellt sein der
aufbau einer neuen kommunalen
infrastruktur wird jahre dauern allein
im aartal fast vier milliarden euro
kosten neben finanzieller hilfe ist
cornelia weigandt aber noch mehr wichtig
koordination mit weitblick und zwar
bundesweit über grenzen hinweg
mitteleuropa lebt man mehrheitlich an
wasserwegen schon immer seit der
römerzeit und insofern betrifft das was
uns jetzt heimgesucht hat die gefahr
dass es millionen von menschen in europa
heimsuchen kann und dann ist es hier
auch eine modellregion zu zeigen wie
kann man zukünftig an solchen
fließgewässern in tälern überhaupt
sinnvoll leben einen brief an die
bundeskanzlerin und die
rheinland-pfälzische ministerpräsidentin
hat sie bereits geschrieben gemeinsam
mit den bürgermeisterinnen und
bürgermeistern im aartal jetzt geht es
darum die hilfsmilliarden richtig
anzulegen
nachrichten das werde ich das schaffen
nachrichten nun von gundula gause
die feuer im mittelmeerraum lodern
weiter in der türkei hat sich die lage
allerdings entspannt und auch nahe der
griechischen hauptstadt athen konnten
einsatzkräfte
großbrände unter kontrolle bringen trotz
großer hitze und immer neuer winde
kritisch ist die lage weiterhin auf der
griechischen insel euböa
die zahl der feuerwehrmänner wurde auf
870 dort erhöht darunter auch
ausländische einsatzkräfte hilfe aus
deutschland ist auf dem weg auch in
italien wütend dutzende brände und in
algerien verloren mehr als 30 menschen
ihr leben
den waldbränden
polens ministerpräsident mussawi hat
präsident duda um die entlassung eines
seiner stellvertreter gebeten
entwicklungsminister corvin trage die
reformen der nationalkonservativen
regierung nicht ausreichend mit
hintergrund ist auch der streit um ein
neues pressegesetz gegen das am abend in
ganz polen tausende demonstriert haben
mit dem geplanten gesetz sollen
rundfunklizenzen nur noch an europäische
konzerne vergeben werden die
demonstranten fürchten das aus für einen
führenden privaten fernsehsender der zum
amerikanischen discovery konzern gehört
wegen des schnellen vormarsch der
taliban in afghanistan raten die in
kabul verbliebenen acht eu botschafter
von abschiebungen in das krisenland
vorerst ab in deutschland haben außerdem
26 menschenrechtsorganisationen darunter
pro asyl caritas und diakonie einen
sofortigen abschiebestopp für afghanen
gefordert nach un-angaben wurden in der
ersten jahreshälfte mehr als
1650 zivilisten in afghanistan getötet
die taliban haben mittlerweile die
siebte provinzhauptstadt in afghanistan
erobert nach heftigen kämpfen mit
regierungstruppen nahmen die islamisten
die stadt farah im westen des landes ein
auch im norden wird weiterhin erbittert
gekämpft aus angst vor den taliban sind
so die vereinten nationen
hunderttausende menschen in afghanistan
derzeit auf der flucht
[Musik]
alle räder stehen still wenn dein
starker arm das will das war das
kampflied des allgemeinen deutschen
arbeitervereins keimzelle der spd vor
bald 160 jahren zehn worte nur sie
packen die macht der scheinbar
ohnmächtigen im kampf gegen kapital und
staat klein gegen groß wie beim ruhr
streik 1889 das ist nicht unmodern
geworden die kleine gewerkschaft der
lokomotivführer die nur einen bruchteil
der bahn mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter vertritt lässt die räder des
riesen unternehmens gerade 48 stunden
lang zum großteil stillstehen es geht in
schwierigen zeiten um geld um macht und
egos da spielt schon kaum noch eine
rolle dass der graben zwischen forderung
und angebot auf den ersten blick total
überbrückbar aussieht der arbeitskampf
beginnt volle kraft voraus isabel de la
vega berichtet mitten in der
hauptreisezeit werden 75 prozent der
fernzüge ausfallen bis freitag zug
streichungen und verspätungen gibt es
auch im nahverkehr die nachricht vom
bahnstreik ärgert die kunden ich schon
bisschen
bekannt gegeben worden
prima kommen also meine bahn karte
wünscht gebe
wenn wir dann mit dem auto fahren also
gerade weil er alle die waren total
ausgebucht ist und so haben wir jetzt
gestreikt das war cacau für urlauber die
gerade innerhalb von deutschland urlaub
machen und dann ein paar züge fahren die
dann aber jetzt in der pandemie lage
dann gestoppt voll sind wenn da mal
nichts passiert mit angriffslust und
klassenkampf rhetorik präsentiert der
gewerkschaftschef seine
streikankündigung wer den arbeiten und
arbeitnehmern in die taschen greifen
will und sich selbst schauen los bedient
der hat eine antwort verdient wie wir
sie geben werden sich selbst schamlos
bedienen fakt ist dass die bahn manager
zuletzt auf boni und gehaltssteigerungen
verzichtet haben für ihre mitglieder
fordert die gdl lohnsteigerungen
insgesamt 3,2 prozent und einen corona
bonus von 600 euro die deutsche bahn
bietet 3,2 prozent mehr lohn doch erst
ab dem kommenden jahr und ohne bonus
mann liegt nicht so weit auseinander
warum dann überhaupt ein streik es geht
um einen machtkampf zwischen der kleinen
gdl und ihrer großen
konkurrenzgewerkschaft der evg der die
meisten mitglieder gewinnt hat bei den
tarifabschlüssen das sagen so will es
das neue tarif einheits gesetz mit einem
erfolgreichen streik kann die gdl für
sich werben sie wollen mehr mitglieder
sie wollen mehr einfluss und dieses
alles können sie nur erreichen zu lasten
der evg und das führt zu einer
kraftprobe die den konzern als ganzes
unter erheblichen druck setzt corona
ausfälle flut schäden und ein
milliardenverlust im ersten halbjahr für
die bahn wäre eine streikserie eine
weitere große belastung die man gern
abwenden würde
ich appelliere dass sie zurückkommen an
den verhandlungstisch und das ist
sicherlich in der lage diese themen in
kürzester zeit zu lösen ohne dass wir
die kunden kunden in dieser art und
weise belasten die sind jetzt auf
ersatzfahrpläne der bahn angewiesen und
die versprochenen großzügigen regelungen
zur umbuchungen und stornierungen
frank als erstes wurden heute abend die
güterzüge bestreikt zwei uhr nachts
kommen die passagiere dran was bedeutet
das für die versorgung der wirtschaft
die ist ja ohnehin schon ziemlich
gestresst ja und so waren sich die
chefvolkswirte die wirtschaftsforscher
die verbandsvertreter heute in zwei
punkten einig erstens es kommt zur
unzeit die wirtschaft kämpft bereits an
vielen ort mit lieferschwierigkeiten und
das können sie sich jetzt noch zuspitzen
wenn es nun auch noch auf der schiene
engpässe gebe tenor der experten das
handeln der gdl könne die schwierige
erholung der deutschen wirtschaft
gefährden vor allem dann und das war der
zweite wichtige aspekt sollten sich
diese arbeitskämpfe bei der bahn
hinziehen weil natürlich immer mehr
teile in den produktionen dann fehlen
können um diese gewerkschaft das haben
wir gehört begründet ihren kämpferischen
kurs auch damit dass bahn vorstände und
manager angeblich geld abgreifen während
das personal de facto lohnkürzungen
kriegt was ist da dran wer claus
weselsky erneuerte heute seine vorwürfe
diesbezüglich ja sogar nochmal die
deutsche bahn habe vor den lokführern
von ihren 150 euro betriebsrente 50 euro
wegzunehmen sagte weselsky während die
altersvorsorge management üppig sein und
da würden wir so der gewerkschaftsboss
über fünfstellige summe monatlich reden
der bahnvorstand verteidigt sicht
spricht davon dass die bahn seinen
mitarbeiterinnen höhere betriebsrenten
zahlen würde als die konkurrierenden
eisenbahn gesellschaften und dass die
führungskräfte zudem wegen corona auf
bonuszahlungen verzichtet hätten unterm
strich zu wenig für weselsky der sich
heute tatsächlich äußerst kampf bereit
sagte
so geht es nun los dankeschön
des wahlkampfs heiße phase falls es sie
je geben wird soll jetzt beginnen
parteien inszenieren eine nach der
anderen ihren auftakt dazu heute die afd
wobei es da schon beim auf schwierig
wird die kfd ist zurzeit so tief
gespalten das niemals alle nach einem
takt laufen würden die heißen fragen um
macht inhalte und führungen werden
vorsichtshalber dann erst nach der wahl
gestellt dh fdp wähler können nicht
wissen welchen kurs sie am ende
unterstützen aktuelle themen spielen der
partei auch nicht gerade in die hände zu
corona gibt es keine einheitliche linie
und zum klimaschutz keine die zu den
aktuellen bildern passen würde die afg
hat es halt schwer berichtet christiane
hübsche zwei die verschiedener nicht
sein könnten und doch gemeinsam durch
deutschland touren müssen die
wählerinnen alois seidl aus dem westen
und der ehemalige malermeister tino
kubala aus sachsen seine arbeitskluft
soll wo sagen ich bin einer von euch
jetzt noch die querwand hier hinten und
ist dann gleich zur stelle und ich
wünsche euch viel spaß bei unseren
großen bundesweiten wahlkampfauftakt
während er sich um zieht versucht sie in
den wettkampf modus zu kommen vor etwa
350 zuhörern spricht sie viel von der
alten bundesrepublik davon dass
deutschland wieder stolz auf sich sein
müsse die korona politik aber trenne das
land ideologisch in täter und opfer
offenkundig soll doch diese gesellschaft
hier gespalten werden und gegeneinander
aufgehetzt werden wir stehen für ein
anderes modell für ein deutschland in
dem wir einander nicht die taten längst
verstorbener generation vorwerfen um
daraus politischen profit zu schlagen
sondern gräben zuzuschütten nach 20
minuten mitten in ihrer rede bringt der
lärm der gegendemonstranten weiter
spürbar aus dem konzept
ich mag es nicht so gerne gegen gegen
sowas an zu schreien und
musste man einfach nur mal am ton
arbeiten es läuft nicht rund für die asg
ein wahlkampfschlager wird dringend
gesucht in der korona krise bringt die
in teilen rechtsextreme partei kommen
durch die umfragen liegen bei mauern 10
bis 11 prozent
parteichef copala weiß schuld ist auch
der innere richtungsstreit der die
partei zu zerreißen droht
wenn wir uns einig sind und wenn wir
zusammenhalten und uns gegenseitig
unterstützen anstatt uns in den medien
in die pfanne zu hauen um als saubermann
da zu stehen das geht klar gegen ihn ko
parteichef jörg merten heute 600
kilometer entfernt in baden württemberg
es sind keine gemeinsamen
wahlkampfauftritte von ihm und kuba
geplant die beiden ligen über kreuz
zuletzt über die personalie helferich
der dortmunder landesvize hatte in
internen chats nazi vokabular verwendet
der bundesvorstand entschied
mehrheitlich nur für eine ämter sperre
nicht für einen parteiausschluss
verfahren wollten überstimmt ich bin da
anderer meinung ich hätte ein
parteiausschlussverfahren ausdrücklich
begrüßt habe dafür auch votiert mich
dafür eingesetzt aber so ist das die
mehrheit hat sich anders ergeben wir
tolerieren dieses verhalten kanzler
weise er ist gesperrt für zwei jahre als
stellvertretender landesvorsitzender ist
noch im bezirksvorstand
in der partei das ist die zweite staffel
kino copala sprach heute in seiner rede
von einer schicksalswahl unklar ob er
damit das land oder seine partei meint
der gouverneur des us bundesstaats new
york andrew cuomo tritt zurück damit
zieht der 63 jährige die konsequenzen
aus vorwürfen mehrerer frauen wegen
sexueller belästigung
der demokratische politiker seit zehn
jahren im amt wies die vorwürfe zugleich
zurück wegen der affäre hatten
republikaner und auch us-präsident
beiden seinen rücktritt gefordert
weltweit wird heute der opfer von
menschenrechtsverletzungen im
zusammenhang mit angeblicher hexerei
gedacht der internationale tag gegen
hexenwahn weist auf das schicksal von
frauen hin die als hexen beschuldigt
gefoltert und getötet werden das
martyrium von frauen aus papua-neuguinea
zum beispiel hatte weltweit für aufsehen
gesorgt sie fanden unter anderem schutz
bei einer schweizer ordensfrau nach
angaben des katholischen hilfswerks
missio werden in über 40 ländern der
welt frauen bis heute fälschlicherweise
als hexen diffamiert und verfolgt
der sechsmalige
weltfußballer lionel messi steht
offenbar kurz vor einem wechsel zu paris
st germain nach 21 jahren beim fc
barcelona war kein neuer vertrag
zwischen dem topspieler und seinem
stammverein zustande gekommen heute
landete der 34 jahre alte argentinier in
der französischen hauptstadt und wurde
von fans bereits gefeiert paris hat die
verpflichtung zwar noch nicht offiziell
bestätigt ein werbespot des vereins aber
macht versprechungen und für morgen ist
eine pressekonferenz angekündigt
im deutschen fußball hat hansi flick
einen job und eine reise angetreten der
job ist fußball bundestrainer und die
reise soll zurück an die weltspitze
führen das ist also eine weiterreise
nach den letzten erfahrungen
das reiseziel kennt er da war er schon
als assistent damals noch im schatten
von jogi löw hier bei der wm 2014 in
brasilien also weltspitze
zurück dorthin ist die aufgabe eine weiß
gott weite reise
von da wo die mannschaft heute steht
aber man frau traut es dem mann zu kein
wunder nur ein starker mann kann
erlauben dass man in hann sie nennt lars
ruthemann bericht
viel passender hätte die symbole kaum
sein können die präsentation des neuen
nationalmannschafts bauma ist dass auf
der baustelle der dfb akademie im
frankfurter süden bei der
übergangspräsident peter peters eingangs
eine vokabel etwas überstrapazierte eine
aufbruchstimmung die aufbruchstimmung
dieser aufbruchstimmung es steht ja für
die aufbruchstimmung für die nun also
vor allem hansi flick sorgen soll gut
erholt voller tatendrang mit einem stark
verjüngten trainerteam kann kann jetzt
will ich es auch sagen dass ich total
happy bin und natürlich stolz hier als
bundestrainer hier zu sitzen und ein
absoluter teamplayer und deswegen ist es
einfach wichtig dass wir alle hier aber
so ein all-in mentalität bekommen und
das heißt wir wollen möglichst rollen
kennt er alle vom pokern dort geht man
vor allem dann wenn man quasi nichts
mehr zu verlieren hat der deutsche
fußball hat viel verloren in den
vergangenen jahren nicht nur
fußballspiele die menschen müssen wir
insgesamt wieder zurückgewinnen auch mit
der nationalmannschaft aber auch mit dem
ganzen dfb
fußballerisch steht flick für einen
attraktiven offensiv ausgerichteten
spielstil ganz das gegenteil also von
der art und weise wie sich deutschland
bei der em gegen england aus dem turnier
verabschiedet hat das war ängstlich ohne
esprit
mit blick aufs personal und den immer
wiederkehrenden fragen nach mats hummels
und thomas müller lässt sich der neue
nur so viel entlocken die besten werden
eingeladen und wenn sie wenn sie
topleistung abrufen wovon ich ausgehe
dass ich das noch können dann dann sind
sie auch ein teil dieser mannschaft
anfang september wird es dann ernst die
ersten pflichtspiele stehen an in der wm
qualifikation gegen liechtenstein
armenien und island klingt erstmal
machbar für den neuen baumeister
nun siegt mal schön im fall 1 theodor
heuss deutschlands erster
bundespräsident einer kleinen frühen
manöver truppe der bundeswehr siegen
wäre ganz schön beim fußball und nasa
guckte mir meldet sich gegen 0.10 mit
unserem heute-journal update bis morgen
christ
[Musik]
guten abend heute brachte das tief viola
ross noch schauer und gewitter das
nächste hoch elfi bringt uns dann die
sommer werbe und das tief kommt bleibt
über dem atlantik hoch elfi aber wird
uns in den nächsten tagen weiter
beschäftigen es bringt uns nicht nur
sommer wärme sondern auch viel
sonnenschein höchstens heute nacht gibt
es noch einige gewitter hier in
niederbayern und über norddeutschland
ziehen die regenschauer ostwärts ab die
temperaturen sinken auf 15 grad am
oberrhein oder auch hier östlich von
münchen auf 14 grad an den küsten von
nord- und ostsee sonst werden 13 bis 10
grad erreicht und morgen bleibt es an
den küsten am kühlsten mit 22 grad meist
werden es 23 bis 24 grad im süden und
südwesten allerdings wird es sommerlich
warm bereits mit 25 bis 30 grad und das
wetter dazu morgen ist sehr freundlich
sonne und wolken wechseln sich ab in
norddeutschland sind die wolken auch mal
etwas dichter und vielleicht kann es in
schleswig holstein auch noch mal für
einen kleinen regenschauer bei westwind
erreichen
in den nächsten tagen wird es sehr
sommerlich die temperaturen steigen auf
22 bis 31 grad und höchstens am freitag
kann es dann schon das erste hitze
gewitter am alpenrand geben am samstag
wird es dann von nordwesten schon wieder
kühler wir haben ja in dieser woche viel
über die waldbrände gesprochen über die
hitze die ja erst die türkei
griechenland und italien getroffen hat
jetzt aber erwarten wir die hitzewelle
in córdoba das ist also in südspanien
andalusien rund ums wochenende steigen
die temperaturen auf 45 46 grad guten
abend